hey everybody will do another episode of
ask IJ where are you guys ask me
questions than I add to them and I want
to just draw to your attention my shirt
please can we talk about it is this a
pork you possess a porcupine hedgehog
not sure I think it's a hedgehog I've
still got the tag on it probably take
this off I just got it at VidCon and I
was real excited about it and I forgot
about it and then I unpacked my suitcase
and guess what i'm wearing on my own now
I've got the head haha alright now that
we've got that intro out of the way and
the Hedgehog porcupine discussion also
underway we're gonna answer some
questions oh yeah answers questions from
brians who is what are you from going to
pax prime and there is a good chance
that i will be going but depending upon
how tired I am after traveling and I'm
not really sure we'll see man da jelly
do you know how hard it is to actually
try to read something and do this Jenna
you should try it what are you doing I'm
dizzy now man wants to know why I'm
animals because i'm basically allergic
to everything and i travel too much so
what am I gonna do with an animal when I
travel you can't take it with you you
can't take it with you but it's so
annoying the last flight I'm allergic to
cats like deathly allergic guess what
was under my seat okay okay okay yeah
you're so cute oh man that's why I want
a hedgehog der illegal in California but
they're so cute on a scale of 1 to 100
how much do you like one direction I
honestly I I can't even put this on a
scale because I actually don't really
care at all I like I just I have
absolutely no feeling towards them I
don't know why I don't care i just don't
really listen to them i download their
whole album and it's never really maybe
i should just try and give it a little
shot it's really hard to explain it's
kind of like I'm just completely just in
the middle so I'm gonna go with the 50
did I watch Shark Week are you kidding
me are you have you seen a single tweet
that I've sent last week I basically
hadn't even posted an Instagram it did
not contain a shark I've also got a
shark costume another one right here I
mean it's like I love Shark Week so much
then what is this Jenna look at this
shark
wow you get the point sharks are
radioactive sharks are radioactive next
question is there a chance the general
will say yes to a marriage proposal if I
asked her in front of the Alamo dressed
as a cowboy in a big hat is there candy
maybe like a little ring pop I yeah mmm
Casbah Jade you see the Teen Choice
Awards no I didn't for some whatever
reason I was definitely not into the
Teen Choice Awards this year I chose to
watch breaking bad and let me tell you
it was amazing can I do another cooking
video yes Sam I will do have a clean
video and I'm going to do one with my
sister Jenna hopefully before she leaves
what is my opinion on twerking have you
seen my Miley twerk
most embarrassing video I've ever made
huh have you seen my mileage work
another one direction question you guys
love one direction I should probably
give them another chance what if one d
beat you up but saying to you as they
took you to the ER how did you even
answer a question like that because I
have no idea that's weird I want you to
spend the rest of my life vlogging I
sure hope not I love vlogging I love it
every from the first people to ever vlog
before vlogging had a word but sometimes
I don't feel like it I don't want to
talk to a camera I don't want to talk to
people I just want to be alone I want to
just be and I planning on playing saints
row 4 yes central four yes yes and
that's all the questions that I have
today please let me know your thoughts
hedgehog porcupine and losing my voice
kneeling I love you guys I'll see you
next video don't forget to subscribe and
find me everywhere else like Instagram
and Twitter and bond and all that good
stuff and i'll see you guys later